[Music]
hello happy Monday everybody it's me
your boy I guess Eric and that's my boy
Ben Janka what's up Ben boys are here
hello yeah we're playing a game that's
in alpha now it's called dauntless it's
pretty much like Monster Hunter right I
would say so we're in town right now but
just to give you a heads up you know
this game spot live we're live every day
at 11 a.m. Wednesday is the lobby but
technically we're still live at 11 a.m.
so you know if you haven't subscribed
and all that stuff you should do that so
that you guys can get notified of when
we go live but yeah so this is this is
town this is currently an alpha you can
get into the Alpha if you buy the
founders pack but the founders pack is
$79.99 so if you want to support and you
want to play this game I think that's
the currently the only way you buy
stands any like giveaways and stuff like
that basically but in that founder's
pack you get the access to alpha as well
as beta you get patron status for 90
days where you can share a stackable
bonus with your party you get the
Slayers pack which jump-starts your
legend with a pack of consumable items
like health pots stamina pots I think
some resurrection talismans yeah in game
title and form icon founders flare we
have a game special for show you guys
that in a second
chroma cores which gives you dies but
for some reason we haven't been able to
access your our stuff is like locked out
for some reason so we can't open up ours
yup care package all yep so and there's
other stuff like transmogrification
style hunter which in all this founders
manor and a go charter anyways right now
you're at the hunter's board which is
basically where you hunt monsters you
can either do them in groups or solo but
yeah I actually have more monsters than
you now that I look now that I look at
it but yeah that's most of them there's
some cool ones I'm I got a question my
journal right now to go hunt a rogue
amber main so I'm gonna be should do
that because those that might open up
more yeah and this point yep exactly so
and as you mentioned there are quests in
town they'll tell you hey go
you know this new rogue amber main which
is like a variation of like one of the
other monsters or like kill three of
these and basically it's kind of like
grindy actually a very grind so so far
my experience playing this like over the
weekend my like main thought on it is
it's like monster without a lot of the
stuff like fluff in it mmm and that I
haven't had to carry a single egg yet
and anyone who's played Monster Hunter
probably knows what I'm talking about so
you have these weird quests where you
have to go and pick up eggs and carry
them halfway across the map it's you're
not here for carrying eggs you're here
for killing monsters so oh yeah once we
get into like the world to like fight
some of these monsters will kind of
describe a little bit about like what's
going on in terms of like what you're
fighting and kind of like all the stuff
you can actually do on the map because
it's basically like resource gathering
and you know fighting a monster
essentially right yeah did you do
Groupon I guess I did yeah for some
reason this morning I played some and my
group hunt was taking a lot longer than
normal a solo hunt went like so if you
go back to soul show I think oh yeah you
can leave cancel your hunt search you
just going solo
it's the Ember main is not too bad he's
I think the I think the rogue amber main
is pretty much like actually kind of
like a dog yeah but yeah the monsters do
get a little bit difficult more
difficult over time and also just so you
know there's four weapon types of which
you can you know upgrade to different
tiers and to do that you kind of have to
grind a certain monster to you know get
that certain whoa that was not
intentional I've also you know the funny
thing is during that loading screen I've
also gotten like the whole like I'm
naked
yes and it's really because there's no
no textures and yeah also you know guys
I am looking at chat YouTube twitch and
GameSpot so if you guys have questions
or you want to make comments or looking
for shout outs or something like that
I'm a guy here so here we are in kind of
like one of the couple like there's a
couple tile sets I would say yeah and
this is like the island and so basically
one of the things
do is you can run around and gather
resources because you need resources to
you know create potions you know get or
to upgrade your weapons or create your
weapons here we're gonna kill some goats
and get some jumper a night hopefully
yep get some high because you need hide
for you know crafting armor so this is
kind of like you can do this if you want
to you don't have to but you should
because you need a tummy so obviously or
to craft and as you kill more monsters
you unlock more recipes for armor sets
he's wearing I think the strike you're
set right now which is kind of like the
owl bird thing we can try finding one
later there's different armor sets and
different weapons and the more monsters
you kill the more different types you
can build or upgrade them essentially
yeah we're in the phase right now where
we're kind of just looking around for
the actual the monster itself yep all
about that you need it for a lot of the
the armor that you and you're using the
hammer which is one of the four weapon
types you like it mainly because it has
like a gap closer right oh yeah gives
you a lot of good mobility even though
it's a really big weapon and it doubles
as a like a semi ranged weapon because
it's got a shotgun built into the handle
yeah that seems pretty good so I've been
mainly using I saw someone I think
heresy 16 longsword for the win I've
been using the sword quite a bit alright
king swot flare and I like the longsword
I like the I like the special ability so
if you get tab real quick for me Ben it
shows you combos which is another cool
part of the the combat is that you know
it's not just spamming either you
actually have to time these out okay run
sorry I totally all right we're good and
who's gonna happen those ready for it
yeah so each monster type does something
different this one is like I said it's
kind of like a dog in a way it does a
lot of charging moves and you know like
a Dark Souls II type game you're trying
to figure out the boss movements and
what they do see he's tired now so now's
a good time to attack the other fun fact
I think just like Monster Hunter 2 is
that you can like
[Music]
I've never shot it's great is that you
can like destroy body parts right like
so uh so far mainly for me I've just
been cutting off tails so it's gonna say
it depends a lot on the weapon type so
for me I shouldn't be focusing on the
tail gotcha cuz it my weapon is blunt
style and it basically means I'm good at
like smashing faces or smashing like
side armor but weapons that cut are
really good at cutting off tails and
cutting off tails is pretty good because
it limits their you know attack ability
especially if they try to sweep you with
their tail and things like that but it's
also good when you are able to do like
parties to have just different types of
weapon types I feel like yeah it really
I mean it's not a deal breaker if you're
all using the same weapon but obviously
there's Plus their pros and cons you
know the benefits as you mentioned for
each one
Oliver fairs asking how many monsters
are there I he has 6 unlocks I have like
closer to 8 and I feel like there's
still more yeah I think I watched a
video that said there's like 18 to 20 so
I think in this alpha they have two
areas on locks I've even seen the
secondary and I haven't a desert and if
there's like eight just in this one
there's probably like 16 ish okay but
they're they're constantly adding and
changing stuff around and also I forgot
to mention there's one other armor piece
kind of thing that you have which is
called a lantern and the lantern does
different things depending on what kind
of lantern you have I don't know what
kind of lantern are you doing the
healing one okay cool I have the healing
one too I've only seen one other one
that has like like a you start with one
and I'm not sure what that so I think
that one actually tracks the monsters oh
okay so it'll tell you like where to go
and then there's one that I think adds
more defence or something like that but
yeah each Lantern has its own ability
and as you see over Ben's name which is
actually covered by this Pip that I put
here like an idiot let me look at you
can't see my health you don't need to
see my help you move the pit there's a
lot of stuff you guys see up there so
the lanterns that kind of shiny one
that's next to the four little vials
each weapon kind of has its
own unique kind of indicator I guess
cause like the the sword definitely
doesn't have those vials that you have
in those represent your shotgun bass so
that's essentially the sword has like
little powerup clips that you you fill
up by hitting people with the sword and
then you can go into like a mode where I
think you can just cut through whatever
yeah you get elemental Janet Wu he
staggered essentially and you can do a
lot of damage to him here now and the
other thing I want you guys to kind of
noticed too is he has a yellow bar of
stamina under his health bar so you know
the dodging cost stamina running around
costs kamon uh and then attacking cause
Sam I'm gonna use his stamina rather so
you it's their stamina management yes
actually
and each weapon does stamina differently
if you put your weapon away you actually
don't lose stamina when you sprint which
is kind of nice
yeah and some of the armor sets have
like bonuses for like you know like a
baby and stamina so that's kind of where
that comes in also you guys haven't seen
it but there's a there's usually one or
two or sorry there's usually like
multiple phases I've actually done one
where I had three phases today which is
weird different for me the right this
alpha is live for those who have
founders and I'm not sure if it's
available in se a alas core
unfortunately sorry that I don't have
that information there's a wealth of
information here um someone actually
asked earlier jackal asked how would you
rank this against Monster Hunter so I
personally haven't played Monster Hunter
um I'm actually looking forward to the
ps4 version oh yeah because that seems
more of like this the style of which I
would like to play it's been a very
handheld oriented game right but that's
my personal preference but since you
have played monster hunter been which is
also why I grabbed you in here make
sense oh gosh what would you how would
you kind of rate the two if you could so
I'd say if you enjoy like just the
monster hunting aspect like I was saying
earlier the there's a whole bunch of
stuff in Monster Hunter that I kind of
don't enjoy like the egg carrying mm-hmm
this is like a very condensed very
focused like just go out and hunt
monsters kind of things so far at leas
yeah but still kind of prefer Monster
Hunter because I feel like I'm biased
but this is still this is still a good
time like
scratching that itch like right before
Monster Hunter double X comes out
exactly and the thing is this was going
to like there's like almost no monster
hunter like games on PC mm-hmm and
before world was happening this was
going to be that game yeah but it's
coming out on PC now so I guess there's
there's two two places you can go and I
will say just so you guys know like it
this monster in particular might not
look as difficult because he's kind of
just like a melee moose at one but they
do get a little crazier over time you
know I fought one that has like it can
shoot lightning out of its mouth I but I
think so far for me the hardest one has
been the fire one yeah which does like
crazy it like shoots out fire the fire
does like extra damage to you as like a
dot effect and I just also seen an ice
one that if you get caught in like a
certain move it like ice blocks you yeah
like a little bit of time and you can't
like just really get out I actually
think this is like the tamer version of
this and I mean because it's it's like
the cooler blue color mm-hmm but there
are there are different variants on the
monsters they all act kind of
differently the expand the move set and
change how they fight so this is a this
is a good one to kind of break into just
to kind of like your you know the the
basic ideas of how everything works
here's how it all moves it's just here
it is yeah and I like that it ramped up
because I was worried at first when I
was first playing the game I was like oh
this guy is kind of doing the same
you know like it's kind of too easy you
know yeah but um over time you have to
whoo-hoo that's good is he staggered so
the cool thing about the hammer that if
you do a complete 3 hit combo on the
ground and you do your secondary attack
you actually will shoot all four shots
oh wow so it's a big damage there's a
big possibility for like really good
burst damage coming out of a hammer
which already hits really hard anyway
hello falls although and welcome thanks
for tuning in
hello me and then appreciate it and as
well as all of you guys that are tuning
in so far don't mind me I'm just trying
to fix the PIP so that you can kind of
see us there's a lot of stuff top left
was not a good news but I thought it was
fine and then I realized oh right all
the abilities and stuff fix that for
y'all hopefully oh yeah there's like
mantling or jumping oh yeah they got
some some good mobility not quite like
like monster on or climbing or anything
whoa cool oh yeah so just so you know
like where Ben's at right now you are
able to kind of regain your life and it
also fills up your lantern which is nice
I think it's about five or six times you
can use that well yeah and it's actually
shared between the party - which is kind
of weird it makes sense because it is it
feels to me like it's a little bit
easier with a group as long as you're
not like yoloing too hard definitely but
yeah pretty good stuff I should try the
hammer the hammer seems pretty good it's
it's a bit of a sleeper thing because
you look at it all that hits so slow why
would you want to use that because I use
the ax right for a little bit and I was
like oh you know like I don't really
like like what the ax does so the axe
just so you guys know it lets you charge
up abilities like so a lot of the moves
are like you hold it down and it does
more damage along the way come back
normal animal man he realizes like oh
like I can't
I thought hammer kind of hurts a little
bit exactly so yeah like each one does
different things I think I want to get
better with the chain
the dual wheel chain weapons they're
faster and I really like this is weird
what is he doing I don't know he's
playing fetch
I guess oh you just healed himself - I
think it's fine
yeah but the chains are pretty fun it's
dual wield they're faster the alternate
attack is pretty cool because it kind of
lets you throw like it's it's on the
chains and you can kind of like you know
like get a ranged attack out of it
which is a nice thing to have because
with the sword you don't really get the
range attack kind of so much it's just
swinging your sword right so I don't
know that's the kind of one downside to
the sword I feel like and what it feels
really good though when you get the
combos off because sometimes I'm like oh
I'm gonna get the combo off and then I'm
like [ __ ] i mistimed it in like i
totally just whiffed on the combo cuz
like the sword is like you get to keep
swinging like yea horizontally for like
as much stamina as you have and it's
like oh yeah like I'm just you know
going to town there it is it's like that
and when you're in like group settings -
at the end of it here was this thing
here which key was the one to put on the
the banner yeah I don't remember this
throw the flare oh that's that's that's
everything game yeah doing it doing it
takes some time every time you kill a
monster you're essentially getting loop
oh this is sideways here but yeah that's
fine you're damaged either so fun fact
you're always gonna be damage dealer
solo yeah but when you play with a group
it'll tell rank yes you'll be getting a
lot of ease man and most because I'm
failing combo I feel like it's it's it's
all about efficiency and if like other
people are in there like messing with
you I actually get messed up a lot
because there's physical like contact
with other players yeah yeah we're like
sometimes your swings don't actually
like go through right so is the opener
where I I like launch up into the air
and I come down it's the worst thing
when like everyone's already in because
they're all using like the fast hooks
and I come down and it's like you don't
get to go the rest of the way cuz
everyone's in the way of you and I'm
like well I'm swinging a hammer at
nothing yeah I guess borracho that says
the combat slow and clunky that doesn't
feel impactful and if that's the case
nothing will redeem the gameplay I mean
it's supposed to be combat as it's
or so I'd say it feels impactful enough
I actually also recommend playing this
on a controller yeah you could do that I
feel like it plays a lot like that it
alerts the way you're kind of probably
supposed to play it but so every time
you kill a monster you get a 1/3 core
obviously this is the rogue Ember main
one which means you're gonna get more
like of the parts of like the Ember Mane
which is like why you farm them I have
one time gotten a rare one in which case
I got like six things instead of three
and you get way more parts and you need
those parts as I mentioned earlier to
you know craft weapons craft armor
upgrade armor upgrade weapons so now
that you've done that I think it's gonna
open up yep a bunch more quests to kill
other stuff so the road Road Rask and I
think yeah it's just oh yeah boss open
up everywhere you know I walk around
town there was a map though yeah map
would probably be nice I I you know I am
technically smart enough to you know
follow the compass at the top to get to
my quest but it'd just be nice to have
like a small mini map you know where I
can run to and I can see the quest all
oh wow yeah you know maybe it'll go
where they're really accessing is so
yeah I mean technically I have a
controller here if you wanted to swap
the controller I just have to get me on
core good either we're good okay I'm
seeing it for them so they not you I was
like care about you yes I personally
think the combats pretty solid yeah
especially like I said when you get the
combos down now there is a little bit of
that clunkiness of when you're with your
teammates sometimes you're swinging and
like I don't like the hitboxes and
register necessarily because like I'm
hitting them yeah and sometimes at least
with the sword
maybe I'm just inaccurate but it feels
like I should be able to hit the monster
you know what I mean like orientation
wise and sometimes I like miss but maybe
that's just on me so I don't want to
just say that its hitbox maybe I just
need to get good goo boo Gnaeus
it sounds like farming all day to farm
more later uh kind of yeah I mean I know
your if you like a certain set armor set
like to strike armor set which is the
owl set you're gonna farm a la shrikes
or strike variants because you need
those parts to upgrade
that armor and the same goes with the
weapon types like if you're using a
specific weapon type you're gonna have
to farm a lot of that one monster and
there are there is chat where I see
groups going like hey like I'm farming
this who else wants to farm this yeah
okay I'll join that group so now you got
something you want sirs to fight so you
got the rose do the chirag that's the
fire just the rogue one yeah I think the
turaga is a fire one okay that's it
sounds like something that's fire and
the drastic the rogue Trask is the
lightning one I think okay i'ma try to
fire find a group for this well why
don't you go like look at blacksmiths
stuff I guess yeah in the meantime look
at some of the sets and some of the
other things you can build find out
where we're going with uh borracho I've
tried both keyboards and mouse and
controller and when I got into the Alpha
I was hyped
trust me I wanted to like it just not
feeling it that's that's totally fair
and I mean if you're not into grinding
this is a tough game for me to be like
yeah you're gonna like it just for like
what it is um because you really do need
to get upgrades on your weapons and your
armor more so I feel like let's just say
I actually have like I think this is
upgraded as high as it can actually go
your boots real quick cuz Mayan had like
oh so you need so I need armor but like
there's armor bonuses yeah which is nice
and I have the armor bonus so but yeah I
do just sit there and if you like a set
you just keep upgrading it and you could
actually just rock the default one if
you really felt like it I mend that
because there's no real bonuses for it
but they all look aesthetically
different some of them that kind of like
a ninja set the Scout set then the
natural ones more of like a furry
yeah that's the way to put it but so
you've got like different cool like
sometimes you get like this weird space
looking stuff that guys got that
defender I don't know do you have the
defender set yeah you might need to kill
one of these guys it looks kind of like
Stormwind armor a little bit Oh in terms
of like the icons I haven't actually
seen it worn I think that guy back where
you were a head to helmet but yeah yeah
Hades Cooper does make a good point
remember that guys that this is an alpha
I'm sure
things that can be polished down the
road also el borracho thank you for
sharing your your feelings about the
game obviously we want more of that so
if you guys are in chat you know feel
free if you played it to kind of discuss
like you know what you know striking a
pose there for sure it's going on total
like girl like girl like photo like you
say oh hey I'm here I'm ready to go
honey yeah we appreciate you guys being
in chat you know obviously this is
there's a layer was glitch there you
know we want to have those conversations
with you guys definitely yeah
I do appreciate this like intro scene we
get to see all your party members drop
in and there's I think you can change
this yeah a little bit there's a way to
customize it which is awesome the game
killing it with that gold armor I think
that bluish armor might be a dye or
might be a farther I was gonna show the
dye and then I realized that I actually
got into a game and it would look
anything
William Asher there is a set bonus if
you have multiple pieces equipped as you
saw I think it was like a three piece is
I think oh you can't actually mess with
it because you're a know what's your
in-game people show so so now that we're
in a group setting the flares are really
key here because a lot of people will go
and forage and like you know like
remaining looking for materials
resources and then basically the flares
help indicate like oh hey by the way
there's losses over here bosses over
here guys let's let's get over here so
most people will kind of take the first
5 10 minutes to go farm a little bit of
gather some resources and then sometimes
one guy would just straight up run to
the boss and be like shooting his player
like multiple times like so you guys
stop please yeah can you hide your
helmet I do not I don't think there's an
option yes yes yeah there might be like
a die thing or something kinda like
Kylie dude in Diablo III went with a
Scouts mask at the ninja mask because
you can kind of still see your face look
like a Bandito so I was gonna do that
because it's very important to not only
have great armor but look great yeah
it's all about looking good right it's
all about the the fashions
trans more transmogrification I'm saying
that right in this game I haven't
actually done it or seen it but yeah
in the games we're kind of at a bit of a
disadvantage for that because we don't
have the ability to get style cores yet
yeah that's you're gonna see at the end
when we kill these monsters that
everyone else is probably going a style
core because they have the founder's
pack whereas we have like a press
founder's pack I guess and for some
reason we can't open ours and so we're
kind of just stuck not getting style
cores which is unfortunate but hey you
know still play the game still kind of
thing yeah well we'll get fashion at
some point exactly what's up red rocker
and the YouTube chat thank you dude
coming in also thanks to the kind words
for the I think it was a el borracho
just saying thanks for sharing that Oh
streaming guys strummin anytime anytime
that's right we'll be here every day 11
a.m. I'm going get rid of us
we're here all the time yeah we got
Uncharted tomorrow I'll be here with
John Luke oh well we're fighting where
we are so this is the flame one this guy
is really oh he's uh he's a big boy yeah
he's real dangerous you don't want to
get hit by the fire either because it's
it's a dot step Oh No so watch out I'll
let you figure out his yeah it's pretty
good one of these moves is pretty cool
like he does like a little flame jet
thank you sure he's lighting up over
there he's what he's doing he shot the
fire Oh got lava brokeback um when I
fought him he only shot one of those out
of his ass oh really yeah I guess
wouldn't know there's multiple you know
he does more so as you can see the other
guy over there as activated his lantern
if Ben was to be in that radius he would
get healed one job he doesn't one big
AoE wave he's warming up though yeah I
don't know if I like that yeah shoot so
how do you know what yeah that's uh
that's a heck of a thing you can chop
his tail off which is obviously good
watch out he's gonna no leave that to
the throw some artillery out of its butt
of course hoop in pretty much oh he's a
staggered I'll stagger Ino
we try to look at your scammer let's see
if it no okay so yeah this is how the
game changes in terms of like the
monsters they just get different
abilities to get bigger obviously that's
not where I wanna be
well you're good I just hop on stand on
top of him so he I don't know if you
guys saw it but he does this big um like
not 360 cuz there's like a little part
that you can like you know obviously
like hide a stone but he does pretty
much like a huge AoE that you have to
avoid and apparently jumping on top was
the strategy so who knows Oh watch out
this is the same oh yeah stay on the
tail
he usually spins around okay there you
go he's a slowly go slowly shooting fire
this is cool I thought this is cool I
think someone chopped this it just looks
like a rough tail so yeah I thought this
was pretty cool see like he shouldn't
have gone in because because not what's
going on right now
yeah you're on fire you take a dive I
mean some people just want to go ham I
guess I guess maybe it doesn't matter
there we go
there you go oooh he's not fiery anymore
that is that looks really satisfying it
is the landing the forks oh that stuff
is just oh this guy's got like an ice
sword Maura looks like it so I don't
know if you guys saw it but oh he does
oh he doesn't he's gonna see my dolls
are all frozen now so that's the thing I
wanted to try so after you kill him this
this monster we're fighting you can
actually craft the weapon types off of
him like based off of yes and he gives
you a fire I would assume he gives you a
fire yeah which I haven't seen which is
cool but the problem is I don't know if
you'll have enough materials off just
one kill to make it oh watch out so what
we'll have to see if you do or not
because you have like a that is that
that strike goes a strike Tritan camera
yeah
something media about this hammer though
yes it's definitely watch oh boy yeah no
wait does a top drop so just roll it out
it doesn't work that way it might
actually no no all right I'm just going
off a little I understand yeah maybe I
you would know better than I do
oh you're good you're good good okay
someone tell me what you do on the way
down the monsters that was from jbg
Jamie G so along this whole area ohokay
yes what the what maybe these guys are
farming them maybe so that's the
defender set by the way okay you gather
resources as unknowing King for 20 you
just mentioned because you need
resources like ather highs which would
kill goats for there's iron ore there's
like plants that you get I forget what
it's like glut grass something I believe
yeah there can you that for potions so
you can also make potions you can craft
a lantern there's a lot of craftable is
pretty much rank P not bad pretty good I
would be getting like ease I think the
group rating was addy though well
because no one was dodging nothing I
guess alcor's though probably we're not
here we go get ready for it we're not
really what we figure we're all just all
with press people
yeah we're just press right now I guess
or maybe all of the style cores run out
today there are no NPCs that you fight
at least currently in the game before
you get to the actual monster throw like
goats every now and then fight basically
yeah as annoying king fort when you
mentioned you can also solo which is
obviously nice because you're not like
trapped to have to always play in a
party but it's cool to have the party if
you like which is also cool the hunt on
your own sometimes if you want to mix it
up and have a have a good time hunting
smile
girag
yes I'm going to open all these and once
tres is smoked glass and more Tracy
so all those all those are materials
that you need once you turn in this
quest you're gonna see that your um we
can go look at that weapon show you I
think you get those schematics for their
stuff yep joke no joke
so that was the like really briefly see
he says rogue the Char Char Char cutter
and the char sword and the char blades
so basically every weapon type for that
monster unlocks and like if we go to the
blacksmith look at the weapon you'll see
that his hammer which he's using the
strike right now oh here's your rock oh
that that's basically the default one
just re skinned but see so oh you're
almost you have enough almost if you go
back oh yeah I only have two more months
so you have to fight another rogue
chirag which we could do you guys want
to see him make that hammer but you'd
obviously need to upgrade it too because
his hammer is currently 140 the sword is
different you know what's weird it just
has the like old icon I think for the
sword that might be you know like it was
and then there's a char boys I think
which is a duels do yeah I don't know
that must be like a icon bug or
something that's like in the web like in
the any actual crafts weapon I think
just weapon Holies oh wow what is that
this guy's been been going hard at it
that's monster hunting right yeah [ __ ]
good god that's a big ax man killing it
so we can do another quest are you are
you pretty familiar with the sword oh
I'm pretty confident I could I could do
a sword when we show a little bit of the
two-hand sword gameplay here is it
upgraded you gotta meet my god I got
like a mid tier upgraded one for the
sword
we got here hammers axes swords there we
go gonna nature it's it's only 20 less
damage though am I
that's good I mean it's not terrible
especially if you group lunch yeah
are there any benefits to being in a
guild zsn one I'm not sure yet I mean I
wouldn't be shocked if you know there's
like guild bonuses and stuff like this
it's probably just like a like right now
at least just an easy way to find people
yeah
chat seems to be fine too you can just
you know kind of like hook up and chat
you don't have to brave the general chat
you have people that you can hang out
with
hello Kimmy Kimbo welcome light shadow
24 and YouTube chat you can play this
now however the caveat is that you have
to pay the $80 for the founders pack but
and that's technically on sale right now
yeah but it comes with a lot of cool
stuff so if you really want to support
the game and you want to get into the
game you know that's the way to do it
otherwise you know you're probably
waiting for beta open beta at some point
which I don't know if they've been now
instead you can also buy the lower tier
founder packs there's a slayer 1 a hero
or founder and those will the the lower
tier ones will get you in the game for
beta
I don't know when open beta is
unfortunately guys this runs until the
30th of August I believe from the
started on the 18th last Friday and
going to about the 30th of August so oh
it's not the one he had and maybe I just
thought it looked really cool it was
probably that one it's that one looked
like it was red and stuff oh do you have
dyes so you get a whole bunch of every
time one time a time well timed I see
what you're playing at here how is the
social space so smooth for you guys the
game is virtually unplayable when I'm in
the hub world my framerate dips terribly
I know for a fact that my machine can
run it that was from NYC Seoul 17th uh I
start to say I personally haven't had
too much trouble in the hub world myself
now it did chug a little bit for me on
my laptop yeah but my graphics were just
in general not very good on my laptop I
don't know what I might experience been
so far I've been playing it fine but
also I have like a really slick stupid
good computer ok got it
I might just say chalk it up to it being
in alpha and maybe it's not optimized
for like every bit of hardware yet yeah
that could be it it'd be interesting
see - if others in chat some people have
played so I'm curious if anyone has like
a mid tier type PC or something like
that and has their experiences that they
could mention hi foodies what's up
food almost like food but foo and the
good stuff
um yeah as your Chevy as mentioned he
says by the way guys the founder pack
does have a slayer pack so you can buy
the founder and sell the Slayer pack to
your friend for $30 so it only cost $50
for you there you go so that's just
being economical economical we love it
yeah that you get a friend invite when
you do the $80 version goodness alright
so show so some some foraging or stuff
oh we kind of showed that earlier a
little bit yeah look at that range I
swear sometimes like my my biggest
frustration is killing these damn goats
with your sword cuz like I'm like oh I'm
right next to it up it didn't hit we got
a like oh no I feel like slightly just
before anyone saw me mess up that bad
life swung three times before real talk
yeah thank you guys for tuning in to
GameSpot live we're live every day at 11
a.m. we're playing the Dauntless alpha
currently available through founder's
pack only the leaves I believe are also
an indicator of resources right there I
think like wisp things that you can pick
up to move quicker I think that was one
of the Oh like I found him I think he's
over here I think I think lightning yep
ha the cool thing is there's a fall
Allen yeah that may sound like that
don't bother
alright so now we play the waiting game
hey guys GameSpot over here hope so
enough someone else shooting one off and
rose up it's wet don't look directly
into it I don't have my glasses
oh he's gonna he's gonna come over this
tree about that though right oh you got
the guy that looked at the clips when he
was like a teenager so there's an
eclipse happening if you guys didn't
know today but apparently you shouldn't
look at that directly because a guy
burned like a hole in his retina which
doesn't sound me in it apparently it
didn't blind him in that eye but like it
um it makes that one I like TV fuzzy or
something yeah I don't know that's just
what he
if you want to keep your eyesight
together so you can keep playing games
don't look at the eclipses unless you
have $30 glasses I think you two should
just get at it this is three of you we
did it good do it the chat ain't got
time to wait man heck no so this guy has
some interesting move sets they're kind
of annoying actually hopefully he can
chop his tail off because he's either
pain in the ass I killed him this
morning when watch out lightning cannon
so the sword has a couple different
combos he's got left click that I think
five hit left click and then he's got
like a three really and then he's got
the right click double right click into
the spammy that's the long tunnel spam I
have to my mind and like actually
remembered I can I can attack the tail
now and not feel dumb about it
yeah just be careful with this guy cuz
he does a lot of tail so yeah like that
I think he's gonna do his side his
little lazy side to attack probably at
some point I found a glitchy thing for
him though yeah we're like I don't know
if it works so much in crew fighting so
low like yeah kind of like after he does
that move if you're like at a certain
angle and you go to town on his tail
like he like just stays there for like a
long that's time for some reason I throw
it up in case the other guy still needs
to find out where we are how do you get
special like signals like the G from
gamespot that was given to us by by the
developers and you can get different
ones through the loot boxes I'm just
home loot boxes ether course yeah
Enoch Hilliard says monster hunter world
just shat on this game well Watson
underworld is no oh oh you activated
your thing yeah I should probably should
have done it when I was closer also when
I had more but I I'm still in like the
weird mode for yeah and I'm like oh back
away hit Hugh so I can reload do you
feel like it it's shed on this edge I
don't think it will yeah a lot of people
are still kind of curious about what
monster hunter world is gonna be exactly
because they're changing a lot of stuff
up but in the meantime this is this is
pretty fun though like yeah if you want
to scratch a monster hunter itch this is
your best
right now I agree and like I'm liking
the diversity of the monsters over time
kind of hoping to see more and it's and
like I said there's that harder ice one
later which um is cool cuz like there's
more stuff to avoid right like that's
that's the that's the fun part you
shouldn't be able to just go ham all the
time
oh watch out ladies happy no thank God I
like it I was like it's got to happen he
hasn't done anything for a while oh so
don't forget your lantern later but you
don't really know he's like dude where's
our fourth guy man what is this farming
he's out looking for or he's like trying
to chase a single goat like really far
away
what's up milk re thanks for tuning in
from the twitch chat whats poppin guys
we're hunting big monsters for lutes so
that we can one day craft a lightning
sword which is another thing you unlock
by the way been owned I say you know I
like like lightning sure there was
something like in-game chat like what do
we get a little bit two weapons I'm like
well once you get to those elemental
monsters actually hopefully I'm hoping
we can maybe get to the ice one because
I just one's pretty cool and I think the
terrain looked different - yeah it was
icy hello pixel bite
and in Cooper ook baroque I said they're
not changing I'm watching launched the
hundred world
oh no stuff that I've read kind of says
that they are well I'll take your work
so they're trying to like design it to
be more or less a Western appealing
because they think that we don't over
here it's definitely more niche right I
feel like here because it's so hand hill
oriented right yeah like handhelds so
huge in Japan compared to here
granted you know probably with things
like the switch and whatnot it'll pick
up and see it it's a perfect match for
the switch I know right straights me we
don't get the switch version as far as
we know yeah could change we're using
xsplit right now picks up light if
you're curious this is our like
two-person stream room it's pretty nice
and you're real cozy yeah it's kind of
warm in here though I'd love some AC AC
that's not a bad idea I can get behind
that
oh yeah keep going to know by the way
you have five yeah so that's his cue
ability with the hammer he had it was
like the shotgun blasts with the sword
it's like elemental damage essentially
yeah see you're having the struggles
that I'm having with a damn sword yeah
I'm I'm not really missing that that
jumping someone someone in the chat
earlier like sword all the way Jordan
after watching his head from stubborn
what just like that's his run away he
tell him he teleports he's he's pretty
cool guy he can teleport man nice little
touch you know obviously it's nice
because you can't just follow him
visually to figure out where he won yeah
well you'll get visual cue like if you
like that like that yeah there's a
lightning storm around here still there
he is right in front of us where is our
fourth I don't think I've seen him yet
he's gonna get a big old is there f I
have got me I believe so I'm just gonna
not give him a grade we refuse damage
done zero
raphaël pose I want to play this if you
do either your friend needs to get the
founders and invite you or you gotta buy
the founders you know steal that
yourself off it does fill your lantern
though which is nice yeah uh this
morning this guy for me
I had three phases with them we'll see
if you have three phases it could just
be a damage done thing where I wasn't
doing enough by myself yeah I hate that
move so much it lazy the lazy fault
isn't much of it like a way for the like
tilts his head hello like he's doing it
here thing lazy side nope I'm just gonna
run and fall over and then this that's
the lazy side there you go see how there
it is just like that his body you know
so I was mentioned you know it does uh
like the monsters do you have some cues
so that's the nice part of like oh
that's the move I love this I love this
so much and the best is when you have
that activated yeah and you're just
going to town Oh a GameSpot man why
haven't you tried Monster Hunter yet I
just snuck for everyone
I wanna play Monster Hunter double X on
PlayStation 4 for sure where the hell
did that go oh he did asleep back double
cross is the the switch one yeah what's
the one so much 100 world is the world
is like PlayStation for PC Xbox my [ __ ]
that's the one I want oh because if
we're if we think we look one I look
good in gear for fashion man do I want
that fashion in Monster Hunter world
that is like opera I don't know if
anyone in chats played lineage but man
the armor in that game was like legit
and I was like man made me want to play
the game maybe won an upgrade armor
maybe you want a farm armor cuz you want
look good have that fashion turn up baby
Bhd got it perfect like for some reason
for me like there were cool armors in
Warcraft but like it's just the heart
style
yeah whereas like in Monster Hunter
world or like lineage it's more it looks
more real I guess if you could that's
why I like how you can look at someone's
armor and be like he's trying to cut off
the tail guys he knows it ain't easy
this guy's got a thick hide look at look
at how thick that tail is look at how
thick this boy is what's up flashback
grandpa and hey is blue Verve eight
what's up
thanks for tuning in we're trying to
we're gonna cut that tail off does this
ever get hard it gets harder we still
haven't fought the the ice monster which
looked like it was a bit harder I feel
like the fire one was pretty tough too
but I feel like this is this is like
we're gonna do stuff this guy's not as
hard this is like we're done showing you
how this game works here are some
elemental monsters yeah it's like the
they're ramping up right they want to
ramp up unknowing kingsport when he says
it gets very hard I will be honest
hello Corrine Tom you should be teaching
at school not messaging on YouTube but
thanks for tuning in this is confusing
where the hell is Spencer oh that's a
good question
he's at home being a biggie baby man not
here
Jay grim 7 when's the open beta we don't
know unfortunately I don't even know
when closed beta
oh we picked up an aether whisk while
ocg kind of like that right now yeah
yeah that's why you gotta go to sortie
captain let's get it tuck that tail oh
no my time again cuz y'all ain't doing
enough damage you know I'm gonna blame
the fact that our fourth still hasn't
shown it's me I'm always speaking what's
my lifestyle okay
hello game release date I don't know if
there's I think it's it's for like next
year and I think it's actually to come
out as a free-to-play game I think
that's true yeah I think that's true
I hope that he teleported wherever the
heck the fourth guy is so gear Chevy
says it gets really hard like the storm
claw is mad crazy we haven't gotten to
the storm claw yet but man we're working
over there yeah some fire behemoths are
very mobile and also almost one-shot you
I could see that too called it always
tails off we get it we got the tail Co
that's weird it didn't fall off at the
other just teleports so hard it flew off
I guess though
that's one of the things I actually
really miss from Monster honor in this
game though is you don't actually do any
carving which is kind of a weird thing
to complain about but like getting that
tail cut off and then having to run up
and carve it while it's still like
trying to fight you is something that I
kind of like enjoyed can you expound on
that for me a mana noob so when you
finish fights in this game you just get
all the loot handed to you as soon as a
fight stock after the fights over in
like Karnas carcass yeah okay thanks
gears sheffy closed beta is 1st of
September good to know thank you for
that information it's right after this
alpha ends then yes this alpha is the
30th of August so that's pretty cool oh
yeah oh yeah cue him up Haiti hold on
hold on
Bears ah what a jerk I thought you were
gonna have a nice little time there
Walla
he was like recovering from his yeah so
he does act a little bit different to
when he gets his tail cut off there were
young oh he's just dead you got a bent
it here just wail on him this is the
best part is the best part is the end of
the fight you just sold early you got
damage dealer - I don't know maybe maybe
we did it danger I don't even know
understand what the damn the danger
percentages but it's 14% it was real
dangerous mess yeah he's not me that's
almost that would you magnify the hammer
100% Oh carving is intimate says McCarty
carving is very intimate it's how you
get to that guy show up on the damn
screen he didn't do [ __ ] oh no I got an
S even though that guy did nothing
we nothing I don't even and he gets a
reward what is this game this is like
this is like LFR i can't just chillin
and rage oh maybe maybe the style core
thing wore off today because everyone
uses it when they get it and i think it
lasts a couple of days and that's why
they are not getting any I think maybe
that's a ps4 at some point yeah they
have their own launcher for it give me
that hot Wicky give me a wiki the
official dauntless wiki this looks like
text your life I mean a little bit I
need an actual there is a extra life
wiki perfect sorry the fictional life is
like a Dark Souls wiki if you've ever
had open that core I'm opening it up
what do we got real common some some
draft races an electro glass yeah which
means you still don't have enough to uh
you know that's name anything cool she's
got it you know hunt these things you
gotta hunt them over and over I think
the next monster gets unlocked I think
it's like a shrill or good quit there's
so many quests now yeah but you kind of
come up because it's like you face the
next tier kind of thing oh and like he's
like yeah I can make those for you now
cool sweet yeah they're pretty clutch
though to have team revival talismans or
just a single definitely I got overwatch
fuels from that dispenser yeah the 84
yeah it's a loop box everyone's gonna
have loot boxes now you're not a camel
she got loot boxes got to have them
boxes
is back to figuring out this is PC only
okay double spoiler yeah it's PC only
Dan says Busey Cheetos sitting there
thinking about the implications of an
oozy cheeto
oh okay Lucy Cheetos give me a quote hot
quote will don't let's be coming to
consoles well we're not currently
planning a ps4 Xbox one or switch
version of dollars but Never Say Never
oh if they did ask which version though
swooped in on that that open area that
open area that supply exactly demand Oh
ever got some new schematics yeah so you
can look like a Ironforge that's exactly
what I want to do I just want to sit
around town but in the back oh oh man
you only have enough mats to make one
piece you ain't farming enough iron man
you know I'll sleep in I'm gonna make
this now just so I have it so we can
craft something all right gear Chevy
thank you for your uh your comments and
help in yes appreciate it in the
Dauntless stream here he says he's got
to do homework but he's gotta come back
in 40 minutes smart lad you know
homeworks important homeworks important
I'm knowing me I would have been a
terrible person and probably just did
home where I can watch at the same time
probably get rule I can't come she
dragged distracted so this is the gear
the gear screen we can actually mess
with the dye stuff this time and not get
whisked away wheat so you get two
colours primary and secondary you can be
like oh my swag give me some orange and
like white or black like a really good
orange is that as good as we're gonna go
like a white or a black if that's
possible yeah a gunmetal sounds pretty
pretty cool ah it's just what oh is it
because it's per piece okay so yeah you
have to go a knife to it can we can max
it makes it up man you can make some
rainbow looking stuff it's uh we go
that's right huh soon Never Say Never
I'll do that again go gunmetal yeah just
redesign our entire look really quick
yep we got to get we got to come correct
fashion
fashion Sebastien high-fashion Souls but
it's not really fun world of fashion
craft that's fashion manhunter danse
fashion don't don't even happy TV happy
says I sub thank you for subbing if
that's a that's a good reminder that if
you haven't followed or subbed on twitch
and YouTube I should do that so that you
can get reminded of when we go live
which is of course every day at 11:00
but it also tell you what cool game
we're playing that day exactly sometimes
you gotta just you know change it up a
bit I like to guitar you play with the
hammer it's you know it's you sit there
and you mess with it enough yeah and you
kind of into it also their weapon at
some point yeah so hard of juice what's
the oh is that that's probably the one
to actually go fights I just grave it's
telling us to find a hunting partner
find it so it's got to be the Beast
let's do its grave find on is that is
that caution triangle is that like a
you're not strong it's it's a warning to
tell you to upgrade your gear more yeah
that's good
exactly what's up I'm moon woo woo this
is jamming out right now yes killing it
how many variations of monsters have you
found says Enoch um hard to say
- so four variants so there's the army
no there's there's like bit more than
that
rogue one and there's there's the outlaw
bird thing oh you mean like try actual
monster time yeah yeah I thought you
somehow variance between actual monsters
yeah I guess that's true we'll go with
monster type okay it's all I see at
least yeah and then if you look at if
you look at what Ben was mentioning
which is like variants of those monsters
yet there's just a rogue version of
something else there's a rogue and
there's like a like a hard harder or
regular version yeah where the bros ad
is what Flo
let's go throw important questions in it
the one with the H hello the bros are
right here and what you're looking for
might not be here though cool being told
to ignore the caution we're probably not
ready for that I like this this is a new
mixer dr. Rehn yeah I mean granite is
probably just an ice diversion but you
know still it still looks looks fresh it
looks clean
and so clean clean there you go what's
up happy TV we see you I just I can't I
get a kick every time I do that that's
that's really rad I like it man
it looks clean it does I like I put the
smoke behind it so you can always people
hey how soon sometimes you got it you
gotta check yourself before you wreck
yourself
we gotta come correct it's all about
coming correct is the way I live I mean
I love to jump in do all of whatever
that is it's like probably they're flux
or something anything what it called it
looks goopy I'm in and it's and just so
you know you know it sounds like there's
more there's more monsta x - oh is that
what we're here to fight I see bird
that's a nice shirt how old do you think
he gives you any like boom a he looks
pissed he does just like it's gonna be
real good
even farming you've been farming my
younger brother I can't believe this my
normal ass brother that doesn't have ice
elements but man are you gonna know he's
squaring off right now he doesn't even
know I'm here I should get the jump on
him do you have bad mr. freeze Arnold
puns ice to meet you what killed the
dinosaurs the Ice Age we're done with
those are you sure because I did the
awful accident and everything I did that
for you
on a Monday all right on a Monday oh
that's new yeah I'm not I'm not up on
that oh I like that though because like
yeah okay so it's a variant yeah
complete very another nice he's doing
some stuff he's still got some of the
same attacks but they're mixed up but I
like how atleast with this monster type
you cut like you got
your camera yeah you know like is he
coming down because you could dodge that
Oh see that's the one I'm talking about
Sandra nice well so Trust is that trust
the rep trust the rep is stuck right now
he is literally sucked in that race well
don't break him out probably I think you
can't if he eventually gets out I want
to know if it's like wow though you know
like and and it's something where you
actually have to break them out to come
about yes sir that's not we're in the
face oh oh oh he's coming for the
slamma-jamma no oh oh and it causes a
bleed oh that's not good at all oh my
goodness everything is bad everything's
bad you're bleeding man you're bleeding
I can't roll the hat off bro I'm ten
years old
growling cool then isn't that a thing uh
double spoiler how do hitbox feel okay
so with the sword for me it feels a
little off you're also dying by the way
yes I probably should have crafted some
healing things and I feel like the
hammer seems to have a better hitbox but
I'll let Ben speak to that for me the
sword has a kind of weird hitbox
depending on the monster but I'm gonna
I'm talking about the the cute pit boxes
I'm gonna chalk that up to me being bad
but I mean you might say Monster Hunter
and office try it's your your this is a
new thing for you you're breaking in my
trying it out yeah it's true Wow someone
just gave their address I don't know why
you do that but uh don't send anything
get out of there I don't even know if
that tornado hits it does okay
guys down Oh watch out for that slam
down don't do it to me please snow I
like that reload nice touch I like how
it's always it's you can actually get
stuck standing in one foot like if you
messed up yeah it's it just brings me
back to those old basketball games the
free-throw line there's like I could
stick it out no stop back in oh he's
getting tired now getting real tired he
like wiped out for some reason so they
there's one thing I also wish that this
game would do that lost always very well
is Telegraph how they okay they do an
okay job they do an okay job I think
you're right I think it could be more
parents it does eventually show wear and
tear but not as much as you probably
would like it to show yes and sometimes
certain monsters it felt more evident
than other monsters like right now he
should be having some like scratch marks
and whatnot right yeah that's not the
case but so the Alpha yeah it's alpha
those kind of things can this is where
we get feedback yeah she's like in
Monster are no you get like you'll see
the breath of the monster as you start
to breathe heavier and they'll start to
limp as they run away I haven't seen
anything limp in this which is kind of a
letdown but you do follow fine finer
touches could be added I will say oh I
will say though at least it's kind of
cool when they like they start acting
differently because like they lose their
tail and stuff like that yeah like even
they know they gotta fight different I
guess I want more limbs to fall off is
that a thing
dead I mean you can like break r-mo
pieces on the outside of bodies but I
don't think you can like chop off for me
why should I chop off an arm so I chop
off an arm I'm into that sign me up
I'd be in for like an expletive why is
it just a tail like what can't be like
an arm or a leg if you cut off a leg
that'd be a lucky wouldn't feel the move
you know also shock that is that the axe
or the hammer don't have your
traditional just like barbarian
whirlwind
but that just seems like that's a thing
so and Monster Hunter they actually have
for the hammer specifically like it's
special ability is just to spin in a
circle it's been a win baby basically no
it's been the win the monster just get
any bigger like Monster Hunter sighs oh
this is getting real hairy for a second
here you're out of pots by the way yeah
but you got your lantern true I haven't
seen them get bigger in this game so far
I'll have to let defer to chat because
some people in chat seem to be farther
than there are a lot of people who've
been playing progress rise so 10,000
subs without videos that's pretty good
yeah that's his name sorry his or her
name the best games and betas are
releasing that at the end of this month
absolve our destiny - oh I thought I was
gonna be able to goddess and say that I
was fine oh boy and he's frenzied yeah
there's also caught beta this this else
right oh hi didn't I just get that heal
baby she's kind of sat on me get more
heal yeah he's like hey guys he'll hear
you no it's okay I've been doing really
fine this entire time so like it had to
happen eventually this is what happens
when you get a new monster size as it
should difficulty should ramp up I like
my still heal though somehow do that
it's you know oh he's he's a girl sure
go to town boy yeah yeah you don't like
that we go hunting
whoa uh the great Guba says assuming
that's how you say okay I'm sorry
like what your dick I believe they plan
on making bigger monsters at full
release I believe that they're they're
conveying that they really want to like
add to this as time goes on so I'm sure
they'll start to add more and more
things you wanna like are you getting
him got him I think you should distract
while you get oh yeah whoo oh yeah you
just tripped himself up he's not just
the most nimble owl
what he's trying though but he's got
guile sonicboom though because Oh a even
lick this paw
oh he's hired he's going to sleep okay
guys random swing bro perfect ID I mean
a plan that the whole time yeah I know
right
he's still too close I just wanna like
lead him the other way not towards the
haha he and rages like it Monster Hunter
it says Macari a little bit oh no go
away what a I can't believe this
guys he went this way rain falls do you
know if you can get shiny weapons or
armor or for example a weapon made of
fire or ice armor yes we saw an ice
weapon and get elemental weapon and we
have them the schematics for the fire
and the Lightning weapon however since
we haven't farmed those monsters yeah we
can't make them just yet but we're on
our way we are on our way if you want to
see a specific weapon maybe we farm this
ice owl and we make an ice hammer if
that's it maybe a good time ice ice baby
yo bro I'm into this give me some laughs
like that you know or you don't laugh
like that okay yes that's fair I tried
to represent a laugh that didn't work I
gotta try it on you know you'll never
know yeah you know yeah sorry I call him
the chicken even though he's an owl
I know oh there he is I saw his big a
swing we did it hey yo oh shoot
someone's fighting him already
alright he's just shooting tornadoes for
progress guys so we're here yeah yeah
yeah give him the girl there
good old flares he's got the hammer and
he's freaking woo oh you can always get
some some free resource for me I might I
might tickle up on that thing really
quick Oh somebody get them out
I got you Oh get them both out got chase
one hit hammer I feel like that redeems
me for many times I did a dumb thing
alright revive revive don't come this
way please don't
there we go woo don't touch that yeah
don't it's real called
the flares are cool I agree they're
really cool idea
I'm dying ice ice baby yeah you know
we're here for bad ice buns here give
him another one man give him one another
mr. freeze terrible part oh shoot
do I have to look these up you might
only have the ice to meet you I got I
like the though what killed the
dinosaurs went a lot and that's bad mr.
freeze puns something something turbo
man doll mr. chadway will this have a G
ring like monster I have no idea
I don't think winter has come at last
the Iceman Cometh there you go
oh no tonight hell freezes over I'm
gonna definitely gonna fall over here
let me try to at least get this oh that
was a bad one where you show us a cool
party Oh God
you're sending me to the cooler Lancers
you're bleeding yeah you know I don't
know if this heals oh you thought that
anyway I thought it would just heal your
party for a bit I've got oh this is good
this is perfect stay cool bird boy oh
there we go it's topical it's perfect
I'm so sorry guys I'm sorry I'm kind of
not that sorry oh I wouldn't really I
personally am NOT a fan of funds that
side aisle puns are the best kind of
jokes
it's the cult town there's no what
skills of dinosaurs yeah let's kick some
ice oh no you're out of pot this is not
a good look that's fine this is okay
we're fine we're all right oh okay at
least you're bleeding one away
yeah uh Larson this Kevin what should I
choose sword or axe I think you should
play around with all four weapon types
but I'd simply definitely start with a
sword yeah I think sorts easier than ax
access lower wind-up this is bad there
it is somebody help the ax has like a
slower like wine open it
it's more charge moves so I think it's a
little bit harder to get used to sword
is what you think a sword does yeah and
also like its mechanics are kind of
easier to understand the kind of like
breaky and do it unless you're a monster
hunter guy like go for whatever looks
good for you because I'm sure you'll
kind of see the parallels this great
mess around
he's uh oh no it's a real cool boy sonic
boom oh boy oh oh he kind of just
brushed up against me and broke me out
huh all right we got some some people
helping out ten thousand subs without a
video oh yeah you know for some reason
that move that moot that that uh visual
makes me think he's shooting on fire but
he's not yeah he's just getting out
again this alpha says claim rupee what
you need to do for now is you have to
buy the finder founder's pack rather on
dauntless calm and that is currently $80
it does the only way to get into alpha
was called closed beta is September 1st
that's closed beta doh um Macari can you
hunt ask can you hunt with less than
four people on will it scale or will it
be tougher uh I think that if you make a
party with less than so if you make your
own were RT yeah and I think it does
scale difficulty wise I would assume
like I mean it's gotta be
well it sounds like the smart things
crazy if it wouldn't be too easy if it
Oh God this definitely this is a real
bad place for me laughs you had said
okay happy phantoms got me I've got some
more damage yes slower attacks but five
more damage get out of here like the
hammer here oh he just used his own
collagen he's like I ain't lantern up
baby who's that thing get that get in
there and get everybody nice and heal
staying on top of my friends I guess
y'all struggling a little bit here this
guy's been presenting a problem why
would you put you're always calling it
maybe he's like kuba says it's not a T
it's only that much if you want to
support it yeah well like I said the
only way right now currently is to buy
the founder's pack which is $80 to get
into alpha unless there's some other way
that I don't know of stands getting
invited by a friend from that $80
package and or a giveaway if I'm wrong
about that please tell me oh god you are
just getting like slightly healed gets
rid of the bleeding okay so I just kind
of like this isn't a very clean fight
oh no but clean Ruby from what you've
seen so far how do you feel about the
design mechanics of the monsters I think
they're pretty cool I mean they're
they're kind of like like come on owl
beasts is the thing that's been been
done like we seem like moon kings or
violet or the yeah like like what are
they called me and Dean do you like like
hug bears or something now I'm being
told there's no official date for the
closed beta so whoever gave me the other
information lied to me we're figuring
information out live here on the show
sometimes you trust chat and they got
your back sometimes shall I see you
alpha status that's fine
killing it but yeah I mean I think it's
cool monsters have been ramping up I
like the variations I like that even
though you fought a Shrike before I'm
fighting ass grave and that's grave has
it so has some of the same abilities or
similar abilities but also has their own
like variation of that yeah so obviously
got rocked like having to deal with your
teammates getting frozen and freeing
them or having to worry about touching
something that freezes you that's like
already like a pretty big deal you know
so I think it's cool
oh no our pal he got God he did get God
that's alright come over slowly clubbing
it's kind of good to get revived though
yeah well it's like full health it man
pretty good all bears for the wind says
hit man come on give me that full three
shot that's the stuff
and then you can know that new wells
there too so yeah that's right
I'm gonna hit that up for sure
sorry teammates we're gonna take some
healthier so don't pay any mind to me
just gonna it's good that you got full
way I turn now to you oh I'm gonna make
up for it by getting this guy up
okay maybe war the monsters gonna be too
smiley no look away for one second he's
set a trap for us getting your buddy you
know you got it I'm gonna let you do
that no good get dodge I'm gonna hit
this got it yep oh he's dead alright
chill feather under feather ah feathers
yeah I don't everywhere just get him get
it yeah go slow get in there look really
cool yeah oh that's a fight cool yeah
let's see if there's some new schematics
body and on like looking at some you
know all right Oh Gavin sealer it wasn't
nice it was these trees as a dead guy
that's the end viento well remember him
as the damage like danger was up to 90%
I still know what that means
team ranked team ranked e I'm Annie
everyone's maybe danger 89% is like your
teammates were dying a lot and may know
health got me out what's up Malachi
various cool good one I like it
attacking me all they got style course
now like I got an epic aether core
though what's the highest you've seen
yet
Enoch oh there's an epic yeah did it you
killed it I've never seen an epic only
rare yeah we work at GameSpot and that
game stop we don't sell games we review
and preview them very true but I've
enjoyed it I've been here man like
almost seven years or something like
that for a long time been real real like
I'm coming up on my first year here but
I've been doing
game industry stuff for a while yeah
yeah great feels it's definitely a
privilege and it's definitely privileged
to have you guys with us hanging out
tuning in you guys are our lifeblood
essentially you wouldn't be here if it
weren't really sure you got a little
green there we're doing it
nice some good some good common level
stuff hey man greens like uncommon
common rare oh so you should make some
potions Mexican healing potions turtle
grass that's what it was I knew it some
types grass BAM that a bit actually yeah
coz Tito's telling me closed beta s
September first and this is from the
Donna's webpage thank you killing it ah
Kukoc Oh says dying raises danger
getting the monster to flee lowers
danger 100% danger you cannot resurrect
fellow players until you lower the
danger percentage thank you
that actually explains a lot that makes
a lot of sense some good stuff alright
I've already walked past where the quest
goes okay it's fine just get so excited
to go check out you know what I don't
like though I can't jump over these damn
fences yeah I'm like why don't do that
to me let me jump these freakin nooks
that you can like walk through but you
can't jump through it that's like so I
want to like cut corners here and I
can't please add that to beta like that
would that would immensely make me happy
because there's so many times I'm like
oh I'm gonna take a shortcut jump down
this thing to get back to over there I
think you're so cool you can do it and
then you end up embarrassing off in
front of all your friends in town the
wall there oh okay
so there's scrape gloves and a lantern
so interesting to see what the lantern
effects for that is and then there's
also weapons so we'll check that out to
see what all the clock and snow - as
well danger slowly gets higher over time
through a fight thank you scrape now
that one city code three of them and
that's why that's fine though because I
mean like if you wanted the ice hammer
or an ice you're gonna want to farm it
out anyone farm it out so making a quest
to make you do the farming so this is
the gathering person no thank you
quest for days give me these trophies I
can't kill them myself
double dips Grave exact grave question
do my question well do my question yeah
what's all that about efficiency exactly
all right what do we got here where's
this all right
oh it looks like some some like armor
Birdman yeah I like that I like
something a bird ones have like the way
that's right but you got the you got the
blue little kneepads yeah and no it's
got the furry to kind of and this this
is definitely unique helmet which is
alright I'm just looking at the bonuses
here aspects supplied I don't know what
that means but quick just a stamina cost
of evades by 20% that's pretty good what
are you missing
iron ore it's always or every time gotta
be firemen and I get I get there's
crippling pressure to like go and fight
the thing when everyone's shooting their
flares off you're like I see it guys but
I I gotta get like what's your weapon
here what's that's the drastic one
that's the like I'm a silly-looking
this grave Oh looks like a space version
of the other hammer
do you have feathers right now I think
so are you look okay you're gonna call
me out on missing the iron it's yep
there it is here we are make it because
he doesn't have frickin iron look talk
about your cold shoulder why I have hey
freeze the heat is on
that's all I'm out that was just a
that's a postal to give him a but yeah
I'm not gonna show that to this that's
fair that's totally fair oh yeah so
these this these are all this no because
none of these have like the tooltip that
the tell you I see but we totally saw
that leg get iced up at one time oh this
is it's the same thing it's just a
little bit later we're gonna keep going
I want you to farm iron or just get iron
work yeah yeah and then and then we're
gonna make that thing and then we're
gonna use it because I need to see it
you want to see it I need to see it
alright I have to so we're gonna run
around and grab the gather resources
somewhere else so you're gonna fight
something that you can kill fast I guess
we'll just do a regular strike okay cuz
I think it'll still give us weird try
stuff but okay I'm gonna find a hunt
because we also still need to finish it
and if everyone's out fighting stuff
while I'm farming stuff we're gonna be
that guy that never showed up and he's
gonna end up getting a free thing it's
gonna be great
hey Gary - all right we got scary Terry
killing it for all those that don't know
Rick and Morty scary
it's like Freddy Krueger except he's not
as confident which is understandable
it's difficult Jeff's life life to haunt
people how awesome would it be though to
like have Freddy Krueger in your side
he's just like yeah all right oh you're
nice to me I guess
what's up patty toner welcome just just
to reiterate guys thank you guys so much
for tuning in to GameSpot live we're
live Monday Tuesday Thursday Friday
11:00 a.m. play all the kind of latest
games betas alphas DLCs events overwatch
events and all that fun stuff all the
game every game yeah so you guys should
tune in sub follow so you guys get
notified when we go live we also do cool
odd stuff they should check out - it's
usually all right there so I always look
at them like like that's not or the iron
ore but yeah that's some type of ward
iron ores red or whatever so it's
usually along those yeah I'm kind of
like it's worth picking up for the
future I guess yeah I haven't seen
anything that takes quartz though and I
think what that is it's quartz quartz
Joe I think that's how I say it's opal
Phoenix opal is for revived talisman
okay what are your thoughts on that was
Oliver I haven't played it yet it looks
interesting looks random we might play
it on the stream
as it looks like deep combat potentially
it reminds me a lot of what was the game
on PlayStation 2 that everyone hates but
loves but a lot of people love ooh
made by Capcom clover why can't I
remember the name God hands gods me a
lot of God hands and I'm very excited
for it because of that alone
they'll pop up a devil Asian Knight says
I love the guy with the beard it's
poised oh thank you
it's that's actually really flattering
because I'm coming down off of a cold
and I feel really self-conscious about
it nice it's just it's not that
difficult to find except it's difficult
to find so it feels bad though is when
you find an iron ore node and you end up
getting like something yeah
oh well they're definitely fighting but
F that we're looking for we're on a
different mission right now definitely
that guy there's an orange line no it's
just the light yeah get in tricked here
classic rock formation maneuver sorry
guys I'm doing I'm ultimately doing it
for the chat but you know I just want to
show you some resource gathering because
we need iron ore to craft this I see
hammer this really cool hammer that'll
give us a that's not a wall at all my
dude awkward slightly I think that's
like it like a connection thing you'll
do it here we go alright so we need how
many was it ready
1 all right - damn it that's that's - we
can still find another starting node
like you're past a node okay I managed
to circle back around to the beginning
area oh there we go good call hidden
around melted you smelt that I knew
exactly where it was I wanted let's go
there's that hurt herma tight or but
we're good yeah we're just gonna go
stuff you know get guy if anyone wants
to throw up a flare I'm guessing it's
over here though thanks that did you
hear it you can kind of hear which is
cool - audio queues over here a general
gist of words there's so when you've
done it you got it you got a farm that
that's like that's like the eighth or
glass I think yeah when you've been in
certain areas
enough you're kind of like you know like
the four or five zones that stuff pops
up in like this is a place where usually
yes there's only a couple places they'll
run to yeah that's why there's nice to
see the icy level because it I mean even
though it's probably similar it's just
nice to your face
yeah you get mounts for traveling faster
I wish not that we know of
you just got hold shift to run yeah I'm
the good thing is if you ever yeah you
don't to the right because I'm just
gonna throw this off and maybe someone
will like they're like dude you're an
idiot so what are you doing are you even
playing what I think it's up on that
that he's over there we found him
perfect
gathering animations need more work yeah
yeah do you really want it okay well I'm
still gonna chalk that up to you take
take your hammer to like hit the iron
like would that make you might better
like a like a pic animation or something
you know exactly what's going look it's
all about the aesthetic and in mine and
looking your best we're talking about
world of fashion craft fashion series
and these guys again Rock whoo this is a
normal guy have you guys spot a scrape
yet you're not gonna like it it's okay
we're gonna turn this whole fight around
because the hammer man's here been Janka
laying it down oh yes excellent dodge
we're doing it we're doing it we're in
there why is everybody dying don't do
this to me you're fine scary Terry's got
the best skaters dead so the tank and
over to Bob Jones good seeing you oh it
has a scar on his tummy yeah the same
with this grave I don't wish it had more
damage it seems like it's just like
baked in it's like here if he take
damage
he's no down percent so he has a scar on
his chest oh yeah there's one under his
armpit too as where does that is yeah
shoot him in the butt get that boy a
butt shot
you get my stamina back really quick
plating the roofie saying he likes the
art style a lot yeah I like how this
game looks it's got a lot of color and
the art style isn't like it doesn't
bother me at all that spin and moves out
of the way a little bit I think I'm more
about that Monster Hunter world
aesthetic but I think it just because I
think the arm roll looks cooler it does
it looks really rad matters to me but I
think in terms I still think this is
cool I still think the the world's cool
and again it's just an alpha so yeah I'm
sure there's stuff they're gonna add or
clean up or you owe yourself you dummy
you extruded bird what are you doing
dumb bird there we go you can kill your
teammates later team I just do that now
since they probably don't have that
lantern that you have it feels like yeah
liquor liquor uh Paul there cuz you're
hurt he's tired he's gasping for air
there we go that was those four shots
combo so the combo that one specifically
it goes faster and it does a little bit
less damage but it almost ensures that
you get PR oh there we go
boom shacka that's a good stuff I
thought I could like Abe Lincoln without
I was wrong I feel like this is phase 2
or that they've been struggling this
whole time without you
I mean whichever way shots are good
that's fine take whatever damn elbow
what's up Annette Anderson thanks for
tuning in let's get those shots out whoo
but part of me the part of me that likes
this game and it's just because I think
it's like mentality wise is I do
actually like grinding yeah and the
combats like good enough
that's the thing that I try to explain
to a lot of people I don't know if it
was like so back in like vanilla
Warcraft when Rose would just run around
in tears hand like farming for Crowe
blades to sell and ruin the marketplace
that was me entirely and it's like broke
me and I love farming stuff now just
because I'd spend like eight hours a day
just running around in tears hand
ganking people and killing stuff yeah so
I I like like dynasty warriors is a
great time for me to select turn my
brain off and listen to like high school
music and just cut stuff up so I'm in
the in the grinding oh guys it's over
here also because like that there is the
payoff of like okay you know what you're
grinding for right yeah it's like I'm
gonna make a really cool weapon or like
a really cool armor I just gotta get I
just got killed this thing with a couple
more times which just some people like
might not like that but for me my
mentality of like farming and looting
and stuff like that I think it's perfect
for me and obviously there's a
demographic for it but it's definitely
not for everybody yeah I know Oh God
woof I knew we wouldn't do it early
Martina says I love grinding I hope you
mean in the way I think and not hey I
got baited there it's fine you know what
happen where did against our fireworks
come from whoa
what that's a yes and happen hi this is
the website bring the game back please
that super awkward yeah we're back we're
back I'm switching it back it's like
nothing happens why that happened
sometimes the games just got to bring
you back to the launcher and remind you
what game you know
Bob Jones the developer I think got us
that that's sweet fireworks scare in
1982 would you recommend Monster Hunter
more than dauntless well it's hard to
say only because like you can't play it
Monster Hunter like this
currently right yeah so if you're
looking for that monster hunter itch
this is gonna kind of fill that until at
least one comes out at least on PC there
are really good monster games on the
three top sell at this point because
people moved on fun fact that's another
thing that is a thing that you can use
it's called the healing totem so it kind
of works like a lantern obviously but on
what it's like you put any more places
well this guy's pretty brave
oh here Chevy says fun like fun fact if
you kill it when it's in range you get
bonuses oh that's cool so like rare
stuff instead of normal cores okay what
I want to know is how that one guy got
an epic he must have just got lucky off
my last fight I think part of its luck -
but that's good to know cuz he wasn't
even the damage dealer or anything you
know yeah I love that everyone probably
needs to use it - there we go
yeah I've only ever gotten a rare
one-time gear so it'd be nice to know
how to increase your odds yes I like how
scary tears discharging his axe when
guys like so far away that's my problem
with that
oh yeah get him while he's tripped
himself like a dummy I'm sorry the
graphics thing you after we're currently
playing on epic settings
oh yeah there aren't much in the way of
graphics options right now it's pretty
much just like eight different options
and then like three different levels for
them scaring you can just wait for open
betas my guest I'll be your prior your
best bet to try to play it but yeah sure
you can wait for that yeah it's good to
keep it on your radar though if you're
interested I want to say Macario asking
can you roll three attacks I feel like
you can has on you time it right but it
depends on the move I guess because like
certain stuff you can't like roll
through yeah I'm not gonna try it cuz I
think he's gonna do a charge well like
let's say for example when he does that
ground pound right you can roll like
yeah so I don't know that is the same
thing I think this is more of like a get
away from it kind of thing this game
says windows wants to know if you would
like to update man no thank you
oh wait it's to it you don't have a
choice uh also he's giving us a tip here
this grave is if your teammate is frozen
from what I heard you can you can hit
him to get him out yeah we know that one
Ben actually got a twofer one that's you
guys out in one swing I didn't realize
this guy was down the thing popped over
my head and I got very confused not you
yeah clean Ruby I'm excited for monster
underworld playing on Monster Hunter
game on PC will be so nice 3ds Monster
Hunter is held back by system skips
abilities yep I mean yeah you can see
that especially with even between the
double cross version of I'm a 3d yes and
also on the switch like it looks so much
better and run so much better on the
switch imagine PC like I can't wait it's
gonna be good I don't even play my
entire games but I could see totally see
myself getting into it on that platform
that was a good one
there's no HP bar error the only ways
you can kind of tell is when you're
doing oh maybe try to kill him while
he's enraged here I'm going for it we're
going in uh sorry I got lost being
excited about how he begged could get
better leave here there's no HP bar
though no boy there we go tripped him
there are certain like tells that show
that he's kind of more hurt like either
missing a limb or all the damage he's
taken up or when he staggers I feel like
they're like almost dead you know yeah
they start to stagger of it really it's
like a cue like oh you're getting real
hurt I didn't have to recoil at all
Bam's not charged anymore but we got him
got him real good darn I thought you
killed him that would be great
yeah right Ben has his mighty ban hammer
from the chat that's why yep that's
exactly it
you're welcome err mm dark Guerrera
asked me what the best classes class is
so much as their maximum danger that's
because you guys keep dying guys why
there's it's a weapon based so Ben is
using the hammer he's been one of four
weapon types currently in the game there
is a sword a two-hand sword and an axe
and kind of like a dual wield chained
weapon I think that it's hard for me to
say which is the best class I think it
depends on your playing preferably comes
down to preference basically if you like
something that's a little bit faster and
you know you can just kind of get in and
do damage and do like a sword something
that's really fast and you can move
around really quickly you got the the
duel
axé yeah he said gear Chevy also saying
that when he starts to rage he's also
hurt also Brooks eating oh it seems like
it takes forever to kill it I think it's
depending on the people there how
upgraded their weapons are because
that's obviously more or less damage oh
that guy got a rare or not an epic what
is going on it's you know we're just not
having the good luck it's okay we got
three quarter or so you can make a new
hammer to hammer stuff with yeah Romina
Franz Franz AK asking does that impact
of impact sounds of the weapons feel
satisfies it yeah I actually really
really like specifically the hammer
sound and that's kind of why I picked it
well yeah I mean that this you can feel
like the meatiness of the the shotgun if
you're like oh it's a good weapon
alright here we go we're gonna open a
court we're gonna make a weapon we're
gonna fight with this icy weapon we're
gonna end it
we're already a little bit over but you
know what sometimes you gotta go a
little bit over things you gotta go over
sometimes when you run the show you run
the show there you go make it rhyme all
the time exactly
are there other monsters to fight in
this build yeah we fought a fair amount
we can show you though the hunting
boards you can see how many we have
unlock there are more than what we have
I know that much and yeah just
mentioning a good point
the monsters do scale is your party gets
bigger which makes sense here will be if
he can actually upgrade it so we can or
not no I can't upgrade it is it because
yeah there it is we don't that's okay
we're gonna use it might actually be I
think it's got to be less damage so 140
against 130 not not that bad it's not
for the elemental damage that's that's a
pretty good trade-off I'm into it
alright let's take a look at that board
we're gonna fight something then when I
wrap it up what do you think we should
go for what I think we should Duke will
shot cuz I haven't seen it it's got that
let's do it wait okay okay maybe go
upgrade your armor yeah I mean I thought
we were gonna like throw it to the wind
and just go for it I don't know if we
want to leave off on it possible like
that not winning but we could just throw
ourselves good I think the boots
actually boots upgrade them again
killing us here five it I can't I can't
upgrade them blows get the gloves all
right we gotta be we gotta be ready
right Oh
gloves are maximum upgrade now BAM we're
maxed strike it let's go hopefully
hopefully we're good now is it worth
dating that if founders packs this
darker era it's totally kind of up to
you if you want it looks good to you
yeah I mean obviously spending money is
gonna be like your value but yeah value
proposition like if you think that
you're gonna get enough alone time out
of the game and playing you know paying
$80 I want some being told scrape is
easier than the cool shot so maybe you
should go scrape so you can upgrade so
the only thing I'm because this grave is
the the ice yeah oh okay go fight the
fire guys I was gonna say we could do
that well see if it does anything mix it
up yeah so yeah it's a it's total value
proposition if you think $80 is worth it
and you really play the game that's the
way to do it the nice thing about the
$80 founder's pack is I think you can
invite a friend is talking about the UI
and having places like this is literally
a placeholder for the armored thing like
a lot of it is actually just place well
there's at this point you see what it
looks like yeah it's it's there and this
is still alpha and I think they're
thinking of releasing a year from now so
there's tons of time for things to get
switched and changed around it's the
beauty exactly oh man
if that looks like not a good place
unless that's leaves so I don't know if
it was because the guy was attacking
with the sword or maybe it was the
elemental part of it of him triggering
it but it's not as I see as I thought it
would be
yeah I would I like some nice like mist
or something coming out of the weapon
yeah no I saw like oh do you think your
shotgun blast is like nice we're about
to find out you know that's that's still
just regular blast I saw in a video for
like a fire weapon and the guy had the
the long sword it actually almost like
lit the stored on fire as he was
spinning around just like just look
really good
yeah we're not just using or what did he
use his cute so certain ability chains
activate the elemental ability okay so
as he did that the sword like on fire
and that is pretty sick I like that
alright so we got that his hammer for
you guys we're testing it out on the
fire monster hoping that for some reason
there is just do it fire up that
gamespot flare here we go here we go
you're ready for it let's just do it
she's going myself raid man
are you afraid this guy's not afraid
link 4 3 double 5 basic as I'm swinging
he's ready for the day one guy right now
ok so there's there's something like
blue Icee effect that's not normal right
no that's that's a snoop a little a
little visual aid here what do you think
triggers your ice frog not that turn oh
oh you on fire sometimes you just gotta
roll in the fire you know just need help
I think yeah I think it does that that's
that's just that's I'm precious to
straight a monster hunter thing I like
it good times
ah great maybe rat ears license
activation the jump attack yeah it did
look more I see if that's a thing
gonna shoot out of his butt whoo I
thought don't go into that you enjoy
knock me into that little backhand here
we go whoo that made ice sound that dad
it definitely has a visual like ice cube
for ya on the jump attack so I guess
it's a jump attack ah I really wish the
shotgun blast was icy same oh no this is
not good I need to get out from here
me get out from here I don't trust it
but again no problem huh
GUP wants you to go ham dude I'm doing
I'm doing it boom three shots and once I
really like that chain attack it looks
really cool yeah it's like the finisher
of the combo where you guys like that
most like jump rope what's up cyborg man
looking good
[Music]
so is is interesting I know I mean some
some of the chats Oh
get out no ok roll roll baby roll stop
it up a roll I can't roll I can't roll
anymore I'm out of stamina no Lantern do
this I'll do this and then alright we
good everyone everyone gets it up
everyone
does anyone in chat know if let's say
for example we are clearly using a icy
weapon does it actually do more damage
to like a fire monster like it should in
fear like you know logically ooh oh it's
terrible up chilled yeah that from you
though
no I think that's from the other guy
it isn't nice no meaning I see acts I'd
like to think that I'll take it I'll
just say it was this guy keep Slama JAMA
oh there we go
oh he's brain sex oh I need to reload no
wonder it wasn't going I was like is
this who oh yeah jump on it he's gonna
whack at a little bit there we go
can you still cut the tail off with a
hammer Alton all right so my hammer is
the only thing that can't cut but it can
break it's like if I I should beat that
shot up face or attacking his arms nice
dodge there the icy axe right there how
we put almost some hatred to the oh he's
dead Wow never mind the big deep from an
a-team we killed it no fire melt ice I
guess this isn't bolt was our weak ties
you know it's changed so much I can't
keep up on the Pokemon I love it but I
can't do it I'm not I'm not good enough
master of the hunt and dammit
the guy with the basic armor is because
he I bet you just dumped everything into
that that ice axe and he's like I'm
gonna fight fire stuff the whole time
everyone's gonna think I'm so cool
well played maybe he just likes the look
the casual silver damage come on epic we
got to get lucky once right just once
[Music]
alright then yo thank you so much for
playing bang-up job with the hammer yeah
pretty good job with sword - thanks
everyone for tuning in the Alpha is
currently running if you have the
founder's pack which is $80 shout out to
Ben Jay go from cyborg man $80 you can
get it now to play in alpha founders
pack I think that has an invite a friend
it has a lot of other stuff too you can
check that out dauntless calm obviously
but that's a it for us remember GameSpot
live is live every day at 11 a.m. Monday
Tuesday Thursday Friday Wednesday of
course is the lobby on tune in tomorrow
for Uncharted Lost Legacy where we ditch
Nathan Drake because who needs ya who
needs Nathan it's all about Chloe I'm
alright but that's it for us thanks
everybody see y'all later bye deuces
you